Well, unapologetic and you know what you stand for.
But I want you to tell the rest of South Africa what you stand for
and what it is that they vote for.
You means I'm a cloudy on this issue.
I wish I was stronger, you know,
anything, even because I don't believe in manifestos either
because the manifesto is nothing more than five more years of promises
and some, and,
and a whole lot of lies.
We stand for the colored community unapologetically
for the simple reason that no one in this country's ever done before.
You know, we,
we speak for a community that is undergoing a genocide,
a state sponsored genocide
in my view. Our manifesto speaks with coloured people.
It's not the thickest one.
I mean I usually eat it manifesto.
It's a massive document. I was tiny by comparison.
But it's because it's more focused.
It's a manifesto for the man of the sea
because it aims to do for the man of the sea.
And it speaks to the most pressing needs in the colored community.
It speaks the time aspect.
It speaks the gangstaism. It speaks the unemployment.
It speaks the lack of housing,
the lack of opportunity. It speaks to the,
I don't want to use strong words.
It speaks to the declaring services that we see as a people.
And I think it's a workable manifesto.
We're not promising anything that can't be delivered.
I mean I listen to some Political leaders and I say it can't be done
not for the finances that are in
not for the time period that we're facing.
We've delivered a manifesto that if elected we can live on.
Really one of the sponsors.
I don't need these minutes to conclude because,
because what we talking about,
you know, when there's old windshield factors put together,
I said I won't even be blind.
I won't even look at it. This is pointless.
But coloured people are marginalised 100%
and the part that focuses solely on that
will only serve just for the divide.
You know, we need to address the divide first.
I don't see government doing that.
I don't see any political party in this country addressing that divide
saying guys,
we are more fractured now than we will be doing about it.
We must be brave enough in the business.
Here's the problem. What kind of people are marginalized 100%?
You say it yourself.
Did she make that statement when the d L F came out?
In the last minute. In the last minute.
No, she didn't.
It's okay for black people to focus on black people.
It's okay for an athlete forum to focus on white people.
The minute coloured people stand up and say
it's an issue,
it's racism at its finest.
That's the purest form of racism.
But it's okay for certain groups to do.
You know, the first political party in this country was not the agency
it Was the South African Colored People's Congress from the Buka
you know we used to have the Natal Indian Congress in the
in the late seventies it was never an issue
this is
our radical racism in this country has become towards my community
our hostile has become
it was okay 100 years ago and it was okay 40 years ago
but it's not okay in two and three
four despite as being worse off into engineering
so ha if at me as a as a white South African
why would I resume with you
what why would I give you my vote
obviously as a
as a
as a coloured person who's listening to you speaking to their issues
you speaking to their problems
but you're wanting to go on a national level
is it enough speaking to one to one community
which your voice is so needed
but is that enough to get you to the top
or is that really not what your aim is
your aim is to just get the message of it
they think that is something that I'll feel
when she'll stick with these aboard what
I'm saying is not going to resonate with every white South African
do you understand that in the Western Cape
white South Africans in general do not approve of land institution
they okay with us living in cramped ghettos
despite the fact that we were thrown off
the finest properties in the country
what they're saying is Not going to resonate with all whites
and I'm totally okay with that
and you know what I'm gonna go lift you
if I was a white South African and I was interested in makrovich
I go for the NZ
because the a N C has done more for
more for white South Africans than the Democratic Alliance has
white South Africans lost nothing under the a N C
why South Africa should be thankful for the AIDS
the AIDS can't deliver anything and that is why we sit here
that answers the previous question about smaller parties
you know, I thought that the National Colour
Congress was the only political party in the country
that was excuse me
I've got a deal with you right? No,
we understand that
there's something you would want from far and indecent
when I say far and I'm talking about the orthodontist
even though I found out my brother thinks the machine is the same
principle and all he needs a duel for conversation video
but what I'm saying is that in terms of where I see it
where we go as a movement
cause our focus has to be on the current community at the moment
no one else is speaking about it
no one else is doing anything about it you know
when people talk with my time on am I being honest
am I being honest that's what makes your music moments yeah,
so let me just wrap up one to The side and then we'll go to a break
when people talk about us
you know E E
N C a I had a a
a debate about the disregarded boys in on the cat clubs two days ago
yeah of course
you know who they didn't invite us
do you know that we have more votes on the K+ and the a N
C and the Patriotic Alliance together
they talk about us they don't talk to us and we are talking to you
and that's what this is about
we are talking to these
now you go to some of mine
either for the study or to start your own business
that's how we get that's how we get into the world
we also believe that pensioners should get 10,000 a month
it's worth your life
you've contributed we can't have our our own stuff in it
not not in the goal because we can't
and if you're going to ask me where to find money
just go out and corruption there
there's plenty of money in this country
this is not a good company
just go out of the corruption lock up people
lock them up for maximum
minimum mandatory sentences and you'll see things change
the problem in this country is that
leadership is involved in corruption
so there's no appetite to go after it okay
but we cannot
it's not sustainable to have as many people on social grasshopper no
it isn't alright so this Is that moment cloudy?
We're not looking at that valid generation
into the Nazi and new distinction.
Currently, people still don't have a confirmed place in this county.
This is the only party that is demanding that,
you know, we stand.
Remember that this is the man that shut down Cape Town
in the name of the coloured backyard.
This is the man that's getting sued by the city of Cape Town
on a weekly basis for people that he will never know
both N, C, C. There you go.